Steven Spielberg and Peter Jackson
collaborating on a motion capture
project with Andy Serkis I just nerded
my pants
[Music]
400 years ago that could have changed
the course of history was lost The
Adventures of Tintin is directed by
Steven Spielberg and produced by Peter
Jackson stars a slew of very talented
actors including Jamie Bell Daniel Craig
and Andy Serkis Tintin is an adventurous
serial type of film taken right out of
the comic book and it's about a boy
who's a detective and his whole thing is
mysteries and adventure and he loves the
thrill of discovering something it's
like the Hardy Boys you know or it's
kind of like Indiana Jones Lite
generations have searched for it now II
look at this it was long claimed the
ship was carrying a secret cargo and in
this movie he learns of this old ship
called the unicorn in which this big
sunken treasure is possibly located
somewhere list the help of Captain
Haddock who's in the family lineage of
this treasure and him and his little dog
snow he decided to go out on an
adventure to try to find it but there's
an evil man who also wants it for
himself laid by Daniel Craig and they
clash a lot and it's pretty awesome the
model ship conceals a good don't have
the greatest secrets in all history
I'm warning you get out but you still
catch these people do not play nice I've
never really been a fan of films that
use entirely motion capture technology
because there's always been something
about it that just keeps reminding me
it's not real and just keeps saying you
know this emotion is faking it just
never felt real to me this is the first
time I've ever seen a motion captured on
faces like this where I was able to
really get into the story and it seemed
like they were real emotions portrayed
by these people the actors were very
good in this film like I said this is an
adventure serial it's very similar to
Indiana Jones there's a lot of
swashbuckling sword fights fist fights
flying boating just everything I do find
that ship with or without your help
[Music]
thanks
Tintin by the way this is a great
example of an adventure film and Steven
Spielberg was the perfect person to
direct this film if there's any director
who truly understands adventure it's him
the characters are interesting there's
good humor the action is really well
done it all has an excellent look to it
to the technology that is used for this
movie it's just astounding the things
they can accomplish that with computers
how could you let them escape
if sacrifice is shit before we do it's
over she's in justice it was written by
Edgar Wright Joe Cornish and Steven
Moffat I'm probably said that wrong
first at times the story can get a
little confusing a little bit jumbled of
and a little muddled and a little hard
to comprehend everything that's being
told at times I got a little lost and I
had to keep reminding myself oh that's
right oh that's right because there's a
lot of stuff to take in because it's a
very fast-paced film very fast-moving
film and a lot of information comes at
you quickly it's a little hard to
process sometimes those are my only
problems with the film it's a extremely
enjoyable adventure movie it's not
really a kids movie so to speak I think
a lot of kids would go to it and seem
bored and want to play around if you
were me when I was a kid when I was a
kid I loved adventure movies like this
and I was lewd to the screen with movies
like this Princess Bride Indiana Jones
those movies where you're just like yeah
awesome adventure swashbuckling that's
this is your kind of movie for sure it's
very well directed it's a lot of fun I'm
gonna give The Adventures of Tintin and
a -
[Music]
Big Bang
so let me note having stuckman square
what's your favorite motion capture
technology film mine is this one I would
like to know what you think
if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]